geoana qui fait par là-même par la manne
à aller l'ohada loana s'est passé au
moment je suis en vie voilà c est
tendance à l'oeuvre on centers le fini
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
on
s'y fait comment ça dans ma chérie de
chars bah oui samedi au nez rouge
montrent en forme lors la péniche
espères tu viendras nous voir c'est con
ce samedi oui ce samedi la péniche à wil
avec et rim oublie que tu vas faire un
mois je fais comme je t'aime un genou
attendez une minute deux minutes c'est
jean claude van damme
jean-claude au bcd one anniversaire
[Applaudissements]
jean claude sautet mon frère tu sais que
j'ai revu tout est filmé avec mon fils
ce week-end c'est clair alors je t'aime
aujourd'hui quel meilleur d'en voir vite
je t'aime fort super
c'est mon bureau je t'aime à 6
ok il salue mon frère
alors mais aussi je veux l'épouser
je vais lui dire je lui dirai oui je
vois arriver on va voir
faisons étape par étape loana déjà je
suis contente de voir comme d'habitude
chérie je sais que suis toujours là pour
t'aider oui et je serai toujours là pour
t'aider parce que je t'aime profondément
et qu'on se connaît depuis des années ça
c'est sûr et c'est vrai que toute cette
brouille ça m'a peiné parce que j'aime
beaucoup et rires j'aime beaucoup si
vous me faites rire et je trouve que
vous allez trop loin dans tout ce que
vous faites et c'est je pense qu'il
faudrait vous calmer un petit peu je
suis sûr que vous avez tous besoin
d'amour que ce soit eric ce soit s'il
dit que ce soit toi et toi tu tombes a
énormément besoin d'un psy mais j'avais
envie voilà de savoir si vous alliez
vous réconcilier ou parce que tu étais
prête à très considéré que s'il veut ou
pas tu peux me dire sans insu tout ça
voilà non je suis pas prête à me
réconcilier avec elle ou bien oui
peut-être je peux voir et ben en fait
je dirais uniquement pour tout ce que tu
m'as dit tout ce que tu m'as 17 derniers
mois donc ni comment
parce que tu m'as fait du mal oui parce
que meurs tu sais bien que tu en as
lancé tu peux pas dire le contraire on
va la laisser finir sur la lancée des
fausses rumeurs ça m'a fait beaucoup de
mal je voudrais 0 médias aussi parce
qu'il n'y avait pas que il n'ya pas que
sa vie parce que les médias ont relayé
ces fausses rumeurs c'est pour ça que tu
voulais être là ce soir aussi parce que
tu as eu plein de fausses rumeurs qui
ont été relayés que ça tapait dll le 10
mai s'ils savaient pas arrêt dans les
médias c'est sûr que ça fait du mal et
c'est une mère peut détruire une vie
bien sûr de fausses rumeurs donc voilà
artiste c'est çà et là aujourd'hui mais
a maintenant une réconciliation au sebo
réponse
[Applaudissements]
avant le bisou on s'est beaucoup aimé et
bien sûr et je voudrais et c'est que tu
dis que tu dises je m'excuse mais tu
sais très bien que j'ai pas voulu te
tuer non j'étais bien c était peut-être
je te rappelle mes rencontres
heureusement thomas doivent évidemment
mais on va parler
vrai que tu t'excuses te dire que je
m'en
moquais et abbas aussi c est toi d
excuse pour tous les dix ans à ce rythme
c'est vrai les fausses rumeurs oui j'ai
pas tué mon mari ça c'est maintenant à
moi qu'il est bien si c'est
non c'est bon ça suffit
ces jeunes orphelins
[Rires]
mais j'ai pas la raison mais aussi
régler les choses mais bien sûr mais je
n'ai jamais dit qu'elle était enceinte
des rumeurs d'accord avec malice
le café vient pas de souci j'ai toujours
été là on a passé des sublimes moments
elle était fontana bordeaux laisse
tomber ses dépends tactique fonctionne
ce regard avec une liste tu as fait 6000
a fait ça alors non alors je vais dire
oui ou non oui bien sûr un ami je peux
pas dire que je ne peux pas dire comme
ça va j'ai fait le premier pas tu
voulais pas tu veux que je m'excuse moi
je moi c'est quelqu'un à quatre pattes
sassus si jamais tu m'as dit que j'avais
volé tes culottes que j'avais volé tous
humains possible non plus c'est pas là
il faudrait
devant tout le monde
bon écoute en espèces pour sa saison
avec des bijoux art excuse moi parce que
la nasa les mains message s'il vous
plaît parce qu'on va clôturer la série
où ces dernières je m'énerve non ya pas
d où le nom c'est fini tenez comme bouc
voilà donc dans oui oui combe des
lanchettes et c'est sûr est belle moi
j'aurais pu craquer c'est sûr je serai
pas bouger son cul non c'est pas ça
vous les biens a détruit mais bien sûr
mais c'est pas ça c'est que nombre
d'occasions c'est l'écart ne dira-t-on
que j'aime pas bon ben moi j'ai jamais
dit que loana et eyrolles c'est pas
possible
je pardonne joker
vous aimez tout bien complet
je me force
tant pis tant pis écoutez on aura essayé
c'était le jour de mon anniversaire
loana pour mon anniversaire n'ont même
pas même pour mon anniversaire je les
fais pourtant bah oui mais là ça il ya
les revenus
m
[Applaudissements]
merci ma mairie razzy hammadi et
voilà merci à la cible merci
[Applaudissements]
m